mentalist Christophe cool baffles his
audience at a show in schwab ax in
southern Germany he can predict the
sequence of an entire deck of cards or
numbers even secret pin numbers
and cold ice
or even locate a hidden horseshoe nail
the mines magic needs no sleight of hand
only sure insisting it's nice to see
that something impossible can turn out
to be true my list of title but it's a
complete surprise I'd never imagined
something like this would work a
personal identification number or these
digits at the beginning there are so
many possibilities and he managed to get
it fascinating it's a very strange
feeling when someone knows what you know
or what you're thinking they think of
human elements that I've brought along a
50 cent coin heads and tails yeah you
keep me let me give it to you and now
please place your hands behind your back
they decide on one hand bring your hands
forward again and stretch them out
towards me eighty percent of people
slightly point their nose subconsciously
towards the hand holding the coin first
time around like what do you mean sis
get here isn't an exception so please
just drop the coin human to be define it
skipped statistic there are statistics
that I obviously try to use in human
fact if I say and please think of a
simple hand tool most people think of a
hammer and hammer if I say please think
of a flower ding my most people think of
a rose he's a psychological phenomena
you can utilize not samahan con
christophe cook studied business but his
passion is mental magic as a Mentalist
the 38 year old analyzes psychological
surveys and studies people's gestures
and facial expressions and he turns his
volunteers most probable decisions in
two experiments in thought the first to
test his ideas is christophe cooks
mentor vanaf Lesha from Nuremberg they
practiced twice a week the senior
magician has been teaching who since he
was 15
I'll phone still ask Marissa pick out
what really stuck out was how
enthusiastic he was he could tell right
away his eyes were shining the way he
acts his charm on stage he's very
intelligent and has bright ideas that
are quite rare in our profession doesn't
get off eesa other magicians do tricks
that are technically elaborate like Hans
Klok from the Netherlands mentalists
don't need special effects they work
with the power of suggestion just like
Germany's Nikolai fatally who became the
world mental magic champion in 2009 in
2012 Christof Koch followed in his
footsteps when he won the world
championship with a mental experiment
he'd worked on for a decade a volunteer
thinks of a few numbers and jot them
down including a year that a coin was
minted finally the magician hands her a
coin from exactly that year keeping my
this a gristle and stuff I'll give you a
magnifying glass so you can see the
engraving on the coin turn it round and
look at the dead and yara star anchor
viewed so loud and clear what number do
you see on 1888 when this is really yes
the spun and elegance of his repeated
the lingering shadow of a doubt you see
in most people is interesting they're
wondering if there's more to it than
just common sense that's fascinating but
and 15 when people see a magician they
know they're going to be enchanted but
they also always know there's a trick
there to mental magic is different
because they never know where the magic
starts and psychology stops untested
tauba hai unwanted absolutely over
audiences worldwide want to see
christophe cool combined the power of
suggestion with illusion he's even
scheduled for a show with the famous
magic castle in Los Angeles
you